for people that just joined the lab so
basically I'm just I'm at pearls Studio
I'm at her reception basically she
invite because she had um destiny is a
big um streamer in America
so me and pal we don't get on however I
am able to put my disdain aside for
entertainment purpose pal reached out to
me Esther we've got Destiny coming on we
would like you to come on I you know I
thought I thought about it I'm not gonna
like I don't like the disrespect that
pole has so I wasn't gonna do it but I
speak to my friends I swear to my people
in the entertainment industry they're
like you know what you should do it and
you know what it makes sense in terms of
my career I should be able to deal with
people even if I don't agree with them
as long as I can nicely tell you you are
being disrespectful
but
I have never witnessed this in my life I
am not a rude person like I'm not a
person to go and smoke with people
unless you are rude then I will call you
out so I'm talking the whole podcast
Pearl keeps going I still you need to
learn to listen
to everybody Esther I'm
[__] speak why did you invite me on
this podcast so I said to her pal I'm
not gonna lie yeah you just need to
learn to be a bit more respectful to
people even if you don't like the stuff
they're saying don't be saying things
like oh oh you need to you need to learn
to listen after you overtalk everyone
just learn to speak to people that's
like that's all I said I wasn't even on
smoke I wasn't even on smoke that's the
thing I'm not angry person like I I was
literally just like please and I did the
same thing I did the same thing to you
what's his name King riches when King
rich is pissed off that girl I said King
Richard you need to just take
accountability and just calm down stop
getting pissed off and actually just
listen to people if you're triggering
people just can't like listen stop
triggering people just be a bit more
respectful that's it I'm all about
disrespecting people so that's exactly
what I've done with power I just said
just like I said to King riches if
you're saying things that upsets people
just stop it and I said to Pearl right
now the the the patronizing things you
keep saying is very disrespectful I
don't like it you invite me to your
podcast and I'm telling you it's quite
disrespectful I don't like it please can
you stop doing that now this girl's
telling me get the [__] out my house
hey ho hey hold me oh my goodness
oh God they hold me she said get the
[__] out my house
about right now like I just caught up by
like Barbara can't deal with that girl
because I am so [__] angry how dare
you
[Applause]
oh no honestly I'm actually so pissed
I'm so pissed someone would teach her a
lesson I feel like someone needs to
teach her a lesson I feel like we we
need to come up with a plan because
that's [__] out of order I'm so sorry
foreign
can you talk about what happened in
there it was crazy ciao can you guys
just say your honest feedback as to what
happened in there I had a lot of fun it
was hilarious
yeah me getting kicked off please can
you comment on that because I'm actually
filming do I have a right to be annoyed
I think that when I think the biggest
problem is when the host is talking if
you keep coming over the show kind of
like descends into chaos I think that
was the issue she was running into
so was it just me talking about people
no there are a few people it wasn't just
you I think everybody's trying to go but
everybody that's that's what you're
doing a podcast you speak oh yeah
everything falls apart what everybody
did yeah
[Music]
but not no King witches are talking over
people at some point
guys I was quiet for quite a bit Yeah he
was talking a lot but she wasn't talking
to older people I think that the main
issue is that this would be my advice
for shows is that a lot of people talk
over a lot of people but when the post
starts talking you gotta chill because
if you talk to those too much that'll
get you kicked off almost anything I
think that's usually what people so even
if you see a lot of people talking over
each other when the host starts talking
you gotta chill otherwise yeah I think
so do you think I was in the wrong in
that situation I think so just because
it was her podcast it was her house
there's a certain sometimes she she does
have the right to talk over because
she's the host no I'm not saying no no
no I heard what you were saying about it
but my point is I just said I just said
Pearl you need to stop saying things
like well you need to learn to listen
that that is very patronizing it is but
it is for sure so because it's her show
she can be disrespectful to people
[Music]
I literally said it in a nice way Paul
please can we stop saying oh Esther you
don't listen
it's hard when the cameras are all in
and for her to yeah I'm not sure it was
just it was very messy
but I think he had problems with the
hosting the best way to bring it up is
afterwards yeah yeah but we've tried me
on the show The Host is always going to
win it's like fighting with the cops
you guys think just because she's the
host she can be disrespectful to people
no in a way yeah well no no yeah she can
be and then at that point you can either
leave or you yeah yeah because they're
showing you're like in their Kingdom
it's like their world you know you know
what it is because you know what PO is
are you guys listening to this because
you are the host of a podcast you can be
disrespectful to people sorry when does
that make sense that makes sense it's
like it's like if you're in somebody
else's house they can be disrespected to
you it's like what's that word you're
not gonna oh yeah your boss at work yeah
if you go into somebody else's house and
they're like I don't want you to do it
inviting me to your show I wasn't being
dishes welcome to her I just said Pearl
please can you stop doing this whole
um you need to learn to listen it's
quite patronizing that's all I said what
was that being did she set for yeah I
don't think that was the problem I think
it was trying to talk over her for over
and over and over again
her show also it's okay because she's
talking to me and I'm supposed to stay
there yeah well anyway say bye to
everyone
yeah
like listen guys this is the only reason
I came here today because I watch his
content here and I proper rate him I was
like do you know what me and pearl don't
get on like me and her we've had that
little beef but she told me Destiny's
coming on I would like you to come on
and that is the reason I [__] came
today
[Music]
okay so these people think just because
I'm not the host I can take disrespect
what do you guys think because I don't
think so I don't think anybody should be
able to disrespect anybody if you bring
me to your house and your dish is purple
to me no if it shouldn't run anyone's
house even if we're in the queen's
palace the queen should not disrespect
me I do not care where I am do you don't
disrespect people it is that simple
but anyways I hate I I'm listening to
what the other guys are saying so
they're saying just because it was
Pearl's show
um she can disrespect me I don't agree
with that I I definitely don't agree
please can you come and say something
we've got 300 people alive
come on come and speak to this lovely
great looking gentlemen
yeah
[Music]
come let's hear from this nice looking
gentleman
this beautiful
what do you think about the situation
don't be a puppet for these people yeah
because I understand when those were
saying what were they saying it's their
podcast so they can be as rude as they
want yeah so they're saying yeah she can
be disrespectful no one no one should
ever be disrespectful especially if I've
got guests in your house I understand
thank you that doesn't make no sense you
can't invite people just to be
disrespectful to them what the [__] I'm
not gonna allow someone to be
disrespectful to me just because that
don't make no sense the problem they'd
be nice to me I'll be nice to them
that's how that's how life Works simple
as thank you
they got my 300 people yeah
you
know I want someone to join me online
someone join me on live right now
because I want to go and live with
someone I want to hear someone else's
opinion on this because these people
like that were on the guests on the show
they were saying that it's okay to be
disrespectful because it's her house so
I want someone to come on live and I
want to hear your opinion as well
because I've explained the situation I
want to hear what people have to say
yes she has it out for me because I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna flip and listen
to what she's saying at the end of the
day I respect myself I respect myself
highly and I will not allow anyone to
disrespect me especially when you invite
me into your flipping podcast right okay
let me get someone else
okay
DJ Magic J okay I want to hear people's
opinion
people's opinion about this oh and
Batman that was that was post security
system where is she is this here I see
what those guys were saying here but
just like what the brother said I'm on
that brother's side to just come to the
camera respect those both ways but I
understand I know how you are me and you
are sort of the same like if we had
something [__] we'll open our mouth
and say it there and then no hoes boss
but
sometimes you have to do this and wait
to the end of the podcast and then pull
a rock bar at the same time
but at the same time yeah I feel say she
had it in for you from day one that's
why she invited you to embarrass you
know what I'm saying so in the day don't
[__] with her don't vote if she tries to
invite you know six months
it was because I got advice from people
before going on the show I got advice
like should I do it because obviously me
and pal I know she's always been
disrespectful from day one and I got
advice from people and they said listen
for your career obviously you are a
content creator this is what you do the
exposure is good Destiny was on the
panel I like Destiny you know I'm a big
fan of his work so I'm like you know
what as part of my career it means I'm
going to be face to face with people
that I don't like don't like yeah but
that's the thing that's the challenge so
whatever content comes out yeah just
crop your parts and put it on your
platforms to build you up [__] it and
don't [__] just yell ever again and
just continue your career because
remember look how long before I know you
feel like nearly over seven plus years
yeah it's all over than that yeah yeah
from when you had like 2 000 followers
to rascular so in a day do you have to
do yet and build your career and be
successful in it you hear what I'm
saying
don't watch no fees even what that
brother was saying here is true what a
brother was saying just now like I
respect what he's saying you know what
I'm saying so just do what the [__] you
have to do yeah and just keep stepances
I'm just being real because you're
grinding with things
I'm just so upset because I feel so
powerless don't don't [__] it it happens
I've been for it millions of times
people I've been through it millions of
times
you
[Music]
don't watch that you you have got the
power you got the Niger power
all right
so don't watch that you're gonna be on
many more platforms you hear what I'm
saying in God's name you're gonna be on
MTV bet and all them things there so so
forget about these pagans who wants to
just undermine you and whatnot forget
about them don't watch that look I've
got fighting I've got something planned
here because I got invited to a radio
station this this Saturday coming yeah
to do a show he says a popular African
radio station I'm I was surprised when
my first show when I whenever I get my
first show I'm gonna call you and say
sister
be my co-host for this show and do what
the [__] you're gonna do don't watch
that
yeah
come on man you know I love you man get
me get my cameras for years but to stay
focused and just do you do what you have
to do babes don't worry about these
pagans let's do what you have to do
yeah obviously I'm just angry I know
anything to happen
from my patrol
pay for my my time for you to happen it
happens to the best of us
I know trust me just take to take it
just take it as a picture so and go do
you know what I'm gonna grow from this
just I'll take it as an energy source to
do better you get what I'm saying grow
with what you're doing you got your own
platform you're not on her career
platform you're not part of her you've
got your own [__] going on so don't
watch that this is also the extended
thing to network you networked [__] up
and go home and just do your things
start first tomorrow morning
's cool
but yeah but I will not saying I hate
what they're saying but in the day that
they're still puppets on the stream I
think maybe black people
[Music]
exactly that's the way
exactly you respect
if you're rich you don't matter like if
you're like if your house broke don't
come and be disrespected
on road bro you're good hey
I'm talking about oh it's my [__]
hell get the [__] out are you dumb peace
not on roads I'm glad I'm not a hood
girl but that honestly I I just I can't
I know I know you see me yeah you see me
yeah
take off my clothes and go about my
business and I don't